hi there today we'll look at imagenet
classification with deep convolutional
neural networks by alex krashewski
elias sutskiver and jeffrey e hinton so
this paper is another one in the
installment of our historical paper
overview
where we go through kind of old papers
that were or weren't very
impactful and see what people
knew at the time already how this
developed and so on of course this paper
here
also known as alexnet was the one that
started the deep learning revolution so
to say
um or at least contributed in large part
to it it was the
first paper that showed that you could
train these very deep neural networks
and very deep in here is a
relative term but the first one that
showed that you could actually
use cuda gpus
to train those large networks
efficiently and it
won the imagenet competition that year
and it did so
uh by a very very large margin
so kind of shook the world um because
previously computer vision was still
doing like hand engineered
features and then using some kind of
classifiers on top of those
this paper basically changed everything
so we'll go through the paper and we'll
see
what was already known and especially
i always enjoy with these papers how did
the choices that people make back then
how did they pull through to today sort
of
what arbitrary choices that alex
krazewski made
right here are we still doing today and
what have we
learned since then so the paper is
written
relatively straightforward i have to say
um it's a good read if you want to read
it and
you know straightforward and sort of
gives you a little bit of an intuition
of how much work must have gone
into this which is i guess a lot and
yeah so they start off by saying
that that current approaches to object
recognition make essential use
of machine learning methods this was
also new right object recognition
wasn't always learned the you know
object recognizers you could
even do it in the in different way like
matching templates and so on
machine learning was still one of the
methods used
and of course today it's the method used
to improve their performance we can
collect larger data sets learn more
powerful models
and use better techniques for preventing
overfitting
until recently data sets of labeled
images were relatively small on the
orders of tens of thousands of images
okay so this this especially at norb or
here the c410 or c4100 these are you
know relatively small data sets with
relatively small images as well like
c410 is 32 by 32 pixels
so they're saying that okay in these
small data sets you know you can
you can solve it with classical computer
vision models
but if you have larger data sets and
especially more realistic data sets like
bigger resolution and so on you need
bigger models so
they say but objects in realistic
settings exhibit considerable
variability
to learn to recognize them it is
necessary to use
much larger training sets okay
so they say that this imagenet data
dataset
is one of those larger data sets
consists of 15 million
labeled high resolution images in over
22 000 categories and
people keep uh forgetting this and as i
am
included in that group of people that
the
imagenet data set is actually much
larger than we know than we
when we talk of imagenet when we speak
of imagenet we
think of the imagenet that has a
thousand classes and about one
or one and a half million images however
that's only a subset
of the much much larger uh imagenet
dataset
with in many many more categories
um it's just that the imagenet
competitions were performed on this
subset
because i guess people thought well a
thousand classes and a million images is
already plenty
so we'll do that so that's i guess how
that came to be
so their argument is right here to learn
about thousands of objects from millions
of images we need a model with a
large learning capacity however the
immense complexity of object recognition
task means that this
problem this problem cannot be specified
even by a data set as large as imagenet
so our model should also
have lots of prior knowledge to
compensate for all the data we don't
have
so their their main argument for using
neural networks is
that the size of the data set is so
large
therefore we need a large model you know
granted they already recognize the
the inherent the inherent uh connection
between
large models and a lot of complex data
but in the the opposite they say well
even if we have
that much data the task we are trying to
solve object recognition
is way more complicated than the amount
of data we have
so our model should also have
lots of prior knowledge to compensate
for all the data
we don't have remember at this time
convolutional neural networks weren't
really you know known to do anything i
guess
i guess they were used for handwritten
digit recognition and so on and were
kind of on par with
other methods however it wasn't like
obviously
clear that you would use them for image
recognition so
here they make they have to make like a
a argument to convince
people that okay we can use neural
networks for this tasks
because they have such a high capacity
how however
neural networks feed forward neural
networks are already
too powerful they don't know anything
about the data everything's connected to
everything
and they argue right here our model
should have lots of prior knowledge to
compensate for all the data we don't
have
so they allude to the convolutional
neural networks
constitute one such class of models
their capacity
can be controlled by varying the depth
and breadth and they also make
strong and mostly correct assumptions
about the nature of
images namely stationarity of statistics
and locality of pixel dependencies
so their argument here is that the
convolutional operation
is such a strong prior that is mostly
consistent with what we know about
images that they are very well suited to
computer vision
again something that was not abundantly
clear at the time as it is
right now uh it's interesting to see how
they get to this point where they say we
need lots of capacity but we also need a
model
with lots of prior knowledge and and of
course
cnn's fit that very well
so they're they go into the problems of
cnn despite the attractive qualities
and despite the relative efficiency of
their local architecture
they are prohibitively expensive to
apply in large-scale high-resolution
images
luckily current gpus paired with a
highly optimized implementation of 2d
convolution
are powerful enough to facilitate the
training of interestingly
large cnns and recent data sets such as
imagenet contain enough labeled example
to train such model without
severe overfitting okay so overfitting
was also still
like very much at the forefront of
people's minds back then
right now we don't really care about
overfitting that much anymore
basically we figured out that if we just
build large enough models
uh we we don't overfit which is
strange in itself like this double
descent phenomenon and so on
but overfitting was still a
a very much at the forefront of people's
minds
and they do a lot of things here to
prevent overfitting which
gives them kind of a boost in the test
accuracy
which might actually not have been the
overfitting that they're
combating so they do for example in data
augmentation already in this paper
and they always allude to ah this is to
prevent overfitting
however we know nowadays that it might
not be
the overfitting that's combatted in the
by data augmentation it might actually
be more have something to do
with like regularizing your function
making it more smooth and so on
uh but so you you just see how
how coming from a classical machine
learning perspective
overfitting was like the number one or
one of the number one problems in
classical machine learning you know in
svms and things like this um
so it's it's it's safe to say that they
thought if we built these large models
we're going to have a huge
overfitting problem and yeah
so that's why this pulls through right
here also
the i guess the one of the main
contributions of these papers is to show
to combine this cnn training with gpus
also not very non-clear at the time like
it was known
that you could do computation on gpus
but
the fact that these are you know very
capable
for training these cnns or generally
neural networks wasn't something that
was you know
known at the time so this paper
basically
showed that if you use a gpu you can
you can get that much faster
and that makes it possible to train
these big neural networks
again right here the size of our network
made overfitting a significant problem
even with 1.2 million labeled
training examples so we use several
effective techniques for preventing
overfitting
and we'll we'll look at those and
the end they say the network's
size is limited mainly by the amount of
memory available on
current gpus and by the amount of
training time that we are willing to
tolerate
our network takes between five and six
days to train on two
gtx 580 gpus all of our experiments
suggest that our results can be improved
by simply waiting for faster gpus and
bigger data sets to become available
and i mean that proved to be absolutely
true
we don't necessarily have bigger data
sets right now though we do
but uh certainly
with faster gpus and bigger gpus this
became a this became these networks
became
better simply by increasing their depth
and as you know then resnets came along
increasing the depth by an order of
magnitude and that gave another boost
to computer vision all right so
they talk about the imagenet data set
here
and the main point in the imagenet
dataset right here
is the fact that the images are plenty
so there are over a million training
images
in this uh subset with a thousand
classes which was
you know a very big that was that was on
like c410 had 10 classes e400 had 100
classes that was already
a lot a thousand classes that is
like unheard of uh before this data set
i guess not unheard of but
yeah and a million training images
completely crazy
and also not only was it a lot of images
they were
resolution was really big so
in the order of 256 by 256
whereas previous methods all were like
32 by 32.
so definitely challenging data set uh
even today it's a challenging data set
all right so the architecture the
architecture and there's this famous
graphic
right here um of the alexnet
architecture
so briefly they describe these
convolutional
layers right here as you can see uh
there's max pooling already here
they have dense layers at the end they
do
generally increase the number of feature
maps right here
while decreasing the resolution with max
pooling
so all of this has sort of you know kept
until today i guess they also took it
from earlier work on convolutional
neural networks that generally found
this
to be a good idea and the
important part here that is kind of
special to alexnet is you can see there
is are these two different pipelines and
you know alex
for cutting off this part right here i
mean you just know like just
has the eight pages we need to like we
have like
three lines too much how can we fit the
three lines we've already cropped
everything
let's just cut off the top half here
it's essentially the same as the bottom
um yeah so space constraints and pdfs
for
conference submissions uh ruining yet
another paper
all right but you can see there is this
two this this
two column architecture right here so
this network was
so large that it didn't fit on one gpu
so they had to split it onto two gpus
with the occasional intercommunication
right you can see here there's
intercommunication between the two
gpus and there is also no
intercommunication
right here on this layer this was very
intricate
that was one thing that really didn't
hold until today i guess until
now with things like i don't know g
shard or so
where you have different weights on
different gpus again
um i guess the the invention of bigger
gpus
made that sort of superfluous but just
imagine the amount of
code they had to write there was no
tensorflow at this point there
i don't think there was even cafe around
there was just cuda
and um yeah just this cross
gpu memory writing i i just
imagined this to be so so ugly and
big respect for writing all of this uh
all of this code
all right so they they go through a
number of
important things and most of the things
here aren't their
invention let's say but
they cleverly combine things that were
already known
about neural networks and things that
were maybe developed somewhere
that they have found to work really well
so the first one
is the relu non-linearity now of course
relus nowadays
are like abundant everyone uses relu's
non-linearities but at that time
it was still very much in fashion to use
something like the sigmoid right here or
the
hyperbolic tangent and why is that
because the neural networks were still
kind of inspired by the neurons where
you had
the soma of the neuron and then the
input
dendrites sorry the dendrites with the
input axons
and then you would sum up all the
incoming signals
and then that would go over so in a
true neuron you have this um this
this kind of curve where if the input
rises above this
uh border right here the the
action potential maybe i don't know what
the
english uh term is then if it rise above
that then the neuron would start to
spike
right um and if it's below that it
wouldn't
so people wanted to approximate this
using some sort of a
a kind of differentiable but um
something that's very similar to this
step function and that ultimately led to
something like a sigmoid or a hyperbolic
tangent so people trying to stay close
to
biological neurons did this but
that gives you the problem that in this
region and
in this region right here you have
almost no gradient to learn from
so you can see that they argue
that um
in terms of training time with gradient
descent these saturating non-linearities
so the hyperbolic tangent
and the sigmoid are much slower than the
non-saturatingly
non-linearity this one following near
and tintin we refer to neurons with this
non-linearity as
rectified linear units so taken from
this this other paper they say okay we
use these relus these rectified linear
units
which are not exactly like real
biological neurons
but they train much faster right um and
of course
relu's are used until this day
so you can see right here that a this is
on a c410
and they measure the time to reach 25 of
the training error
and this here is with the release and
this here is with the hyperbolic tangent
and it takes much longer to reach the
hyperbolic tangent
especially it takes six times
uh faster to with the relus
and they say that's one of the main
components that allows them
to learn this fast uh to even experiment
with these big networks
because their entire training time is
six days
right but they probably didn't train it
only once they experimented with it and
saw what works so
if you have a couple of months of time
and it takes you a week to train
one of these things you know you don't
you you can't afford a six-time
slowdown because that would mean you can
only train like
two models in the entire uh course of
research
and that would severely hinder your
progress now we are at the
point where that becomes true again with
these giant
giant transformer language models where
people can train it
once and then you know like gpt3 they
say oh we made
we discovered a bug halfway through and
we've kind of fixed it but we're not
sure
we couldn't restart because it was too
expensive um
maybe we're waiting for a moment i'm
still saying we're waiting for the
resnet moment
in the uh transformers but yeah rey lews
in you know here in not introduced here
but
used here and have been prevailing until
today
training on multiple gpus something as i
said that didn't
didn't really get forward from here
especially
the kind of gpu training so if we train
on multiple gpus
today what we mean is that we have our
model
right and then we distribute that to
multiple
gpus like this and then we take a mini
batch
from the training data and we simply
split it up let each gpu
do its thing on its subset of the mini
batch and then at the end
kind of calculate the loss and then back
propagate the gradients
and synchronize the gradients between
that so we have one model
that is on both gpus here they
distribute a model
to two gpus and i'm i'm also thinking
that with
frameworks like g-shard this could
potentially have
a revival right here this kind of
distributing your models especially
within the same layer
across many gpus and then having
cross-communication only
at some points so their argument is
this only has three gigabytes of memory
which limits the maximum size of
networks can be trained on it
turns out that 1.2 train million
training examples are enough to train
networks which are too big to fit on one
gpu
therefore we spread the net across two
gpus
current gpus are particularly well
suited to cross gpu parallelization
as they are able to read from and write
to one another's memory directly without
going through the host machine
okay so this means that for
so ah sorry here
they say the parallelization scheme that
we employ
essentially puts half the kernels or
neurons on each gpu
with one additional trick the gpus
communicate
only in certain layers that means that
for example the kernels of layer three
take input from all kernel maps and
layer to hover the kernels in layer four
take input only from the kernel maps and
layer three which reside on the same gpu
so very very interesting uh choice right
here
and they they justify this here or they
say the results
um this scheme reduces our top one top
five error rates by one point seven and
one per two percent
respectively as compared with a net with
half as many kernels
in each computational layer in each
convolutional layer on one
gpu the two gpu net takes slightly less
time to train than the one
gpu net so first of all i have to say
big respect right here like like
i can imagine they did this you know
with the relu's and stuff and they were
already better than previous because
they're so just to go to the results the
pre they beat
the error rates of previous models by
like a ginormous amount so this is what
they
knew right here this is on the 2010 uh
imagenet
split so the previous best ones were
like at around
28 25 and here their best one is at
17 percent top five error rate i'm going
to imagine
that they trained it first and we're
already better than the 25 percent
and i guess lots of people would just
call it a day would be like oh
cool we have this entirely new method
not only did we show
that we can train it we actually show
that it's better
and boom i have point one percent better
error rate
and everything else can be a separate
paper no they
stuck with it and they pushed it each so
each of these things right here
they say oh this reduces the error rate
by one percent this reduces the error
rate by two percent
um and you know really they
they went about it how far can we push
this with everything
i mean just imagine you come and you
train a network i'm pretty sure they
first trained on one gpu
right and um and then they
thought ah you know maybe we can train
an even bigger network uh by using two
gpus
and then they realize well it's gonna
take like a
crap-ton amount of dumb code to
cross-synchronize and keep them in
lockstep
and blah blah blah like it's not even
easy to write multi-gpu code
today with all the frameworks just
imagine that
and for them to having already observed
that their network does better
than everything that was previously to
sit down
and do the cross gpu thing uh experiment
with okay when do we cross
communicate and whatnot that is very
very respectable
um right here so
maybe a lesson to be learned uh or or
just the mentality of the people maybe
they just had
more time they were like okay it's still
like two months out
uh this competition deadline i don't
know but
no i'm this this is not something that i
see
today very often um this this kind of
persistence and
additional pushing and reporting of what
works in these kinds of things i mean
some some papers do it
but most papers do it because only with
all the tricks they can get that point
one percent
improvement and this one already had the
improvement and
did it anyway okay but multi-gpu
training
didn't really it's like splitting the
models across gpus
didn't really um didn't really stick
around
mainly because i guess the gpus got
larger in memory
pretty quickly so it wasn't that
necessary
but also i guess because the frameworks
were just too clunky
and now maybe which is shard this is
coming back so worth another
shot i guess next one local response
normalization
this also didn't really um stick around
i got kind of dumped in favor of things
like batch normalization but with the
resurfacing of things like
layer normalization um this it comes
back to this thing here again a little
bit
so what they say is that
uh what they want to do is they want to
kind of normalize the response of these
of these reduce so what they do is each
response which is this alpha the or this
a here
is normalized by the following quantity
and it's the all the responses of the
other neurons around them or of the
other kernels around them
and you can see the sum is over this
weird
quantity right here so what does it mean
if they have a bunch of convolutional
filters
and these are the activations so these
are the feature maps after the
convolution
and um yeah so if i have like 10
convolutional filters
in my layer this is going to be the
output the way they normalize is they
normalize
each filter sorry each output
channel by averaging
by you see here dividing
by the average response of the channels
around them
right so let's maybe say the five
channels though two channels in front of
them and two channels behind them
this is going to be they take the
average across
this one and then for another channel
right here
for this one you would take the average
of the five around that
this isn't really something that stuck
around um
i guess mainly because of the really
dynamic situation
right here what people do today
is they have things like layer
normalization that simply averages
across all of the channels or they have
group normalization that
predefines these groups like here is
there's two groups
and we only normalize within this group
and within
this group also always the same this
kind of dynamic normalization
on across neighboring filters as i said
didn't really stick around not really
sure
why but um i guess
it was just easier to implement it
otherwise or it just worked better
again here they say this
this it was motivated well right this
scheme bears some resemblance to the
local contrast normalization scheme of
that
but ours would be more correctly termed
brightness normalization since we do not
subtract the mean activity
and oh they make it connection to
biological neurons
where is it this sort of response
normalization implements a form of
lateral inhibition inspired by the type
found in real neurons creating
competition for big activities
amongst neuron outputs computed using
different kernels
okay so kind of inspired by real neurons
but also kind of inspired by
other people doing also some kind of
normalization so people already knew
that normalization
was helpful at some times and this is
what they employed
right here again reducing the top error
rates by
1.4 and 1.2 respectively
so not a big improvement but still an
improvement
the last thing overlapping pooling again
a thing that didn't really stick around
uh that much uh where they say okay
instead of having a pooling layer so if
this is your image and
instead of pulling two by two
in the stride of two like we do today
and you know pull it down to a smaller
image what we can do instead
is we can pull with overlapping windows
so in that case they pool with a three
by three window
but they do always do stride of two so
they have like these overlaps right here
resulting in the same size but then each
pixel right
here has some sort of overlapping
information from the pixels around
it again they say it reduces the top one
and top five error rates by point four
percent and point
three percent maybe this this didn't
stick around because
um i i'm not sure maybe because people
found
it doesn't work in other problems who
knows
so the overall architecture as we said
is described in
this picture right here so you have the
input image which you can see
has three channels and they use
convolutional filters
uh with a here with a stride of four at
the beginning
to reduce the size so at the beginning
it's 224 by 224
and then it's 48 by sorry
it's 55 by 55 that thing here 55 by 55
48 feature maps you can already see as
we said before
the feature maps keep increasing
while the number of the dimension the
resolution of the image keeps
decreasing the stride of 4
convolution here already employed in
order to down sample the image at the
same time as convolving it
nowadays a lot of architectures will
simply
not do max pooling at all but always use
the kind of strided convolution to down
sample image
while convolving it what you also see
here
is that they thought that
the feature map size should d
should also be large at the beginning
and then decrease
which is a reasonable assumption right
because if
you have higher resolution images you're
probably going to need higher resolution
feature maps this didn't really come
through
until today as you know most
architectures today
they just go with like three by three uh
kernels from the very start
and don't really care about you know
also downsizing their
their filters um i don't really know
why whether it's just more convenient or
less parameters
or um whether there's really something
to
having small filters but i just know you
know this is
something the large filters at the
beginning is something that didn't
didn't hold over time
also you can see right here they have
multiple dense layers at the end
i believe most architectures today
simply go
with two of those instead of three so
one like hidden layer and then one
classification layer
but it's you know it's um it's
very close to the architectures today
right there hasn't
changed that much like the difference
between this and the vgg
16 vgg 19 network is just depth and then
the difference between those and the
resnet
is just the whatever the skip
connections right here
and that's where we are today so so
there hasn't
hasn't changed that much uh honestly
they also allude to the fact that
actually even though it doesn't look
like it
most parameters are here in these dense
layers
those are most parameters of the network
this right here a convolutional layer is
like one percent of the parameters
even though it takes up a lot of space
in the in the drawing
so maybe the reduction in the number of
classification layers at the end
also has something to do with the fact
that that's where most parameters are
so if you get rid of one of those dense
layers you can like
get many many more convolutional layers
all right so the last uh part here is on
reducing
overfitting again um they didn't
really investigate uh whether or not
really their network was overfitting
like really establishing the overfitting
it would i i think
maybe they did and maybe it was actually
overfitting um
but we now we we don't care about
overfitting too much anymore
maybe because we already use these
augmentations naturally
but also because we built these deep
models so
um we somehow have an idea that they
generalize
naturally i'm i'm not sure whether they
actually were only worried about it that
much because of the history of machine
learning
or whether they actually did see
that everything was overfitting
constantly
okay they say our neural network
architecture has 60 million parameters
although the thousand classes make each
training example impose
10 bits of constraints on the mapping
from image to label
this turns out to be insufficient to
learn many parameters without
considerable overfitting
below we describe two primary ways in
which we combat overfitting again is
no one today no one today makes this
argument anymore this
oh we have this many parameters and
there are that many images right
we have 60 million parameters um we have
1.2 million images
a thousand classes how you know when do
how many parameters per sample is that
and so on
how many bits of constraint
we don't care about we're fine with
having
uh like a billion times more parameters
than
training samples uh we we don't worry
about it
anymore so the first thing they do is
data augmentation already um
i mean this was already known again like
lots of these things here were already
known but the the combination is just so
cool in this paper
where so first of all again
they say the transformed images are
generating python code on the cpu while
the gpu
is training on the previous batch of
images so these data augmentation
schemes are in effect
computationally free again this code
must have been ugly
the first form of data augmentation
consists of generating
image translations and horizontal
reflections
we do this by extracting random 224 by
224 patches and their horizontal
reflections
from the 256 by 256 images
okay so random so this was already
this these are the most valuable data
augmentations that still we have today
random horizontal flipping is still used
in every pipeline
of computer vision except if you want to
read text i guess
and um random cropping
is still the most powerful data
augmentation technique for images
today and the
it's crazy that um this was already
discovered and i i don't know
whether they say right here how much
this particular
thing improves i don't think they have a
stat on how much this improves they just
say
how much this this next thing improves
but i'm going to guess
this was one of the vital things for
pushing the performance because
now we know cropping is very important i
guess
they thought that they they would you
know translation was the important part
and so they focused on generating image
translations and to generate an image
translation from a single image
naturally you have to crop it
um however we we now
focus much more on the fact that we crop
it and kind of have different
sub images of the same image especially
in you know self-supervised learning
and things like this we know that
cropping is what is like the
the power horse of these methods
so the fact that they uh extract random
patches right here means that their
network only operates on these
sub patches and then they compensate by
at test time the networks makes a
prediction by extracting
five patches the four corner patches and
the center patch as well as their
horizontal reflections
and averaging the prediction made by the
network's soft max layer on the ten
patches
i also believe that people don't do this
too much
nowadays they most of the time
they simply rescale the test images
or something like this or fine tune at
the end on the
kind of scale training images there are
various techniques
for doing this but random cropping
and horizontal flipping already employed
right here
also color kind of color jittering a
form of color jittering a very special
form uh altering the intensities of rgb
channels and training images
specifically we perform pca
on the set of rgb pixel values
throughout the imagenet training set
to each training image we add multiples
of the found principal components with
magnitudes proportional
to the corresponding eigenvalues times a
random variable drawn from a gauss with
zero mean and standard deviation
0.1 this is i believe
this has gone out of fashion so people
do color jitter and kind of brightness
jitter and so on
uh but i don't think they particularly
do this kind of pca based
image image augmentation
right here anymore they say this scheme
reduces the top one error rate by
over one percent
i i wonder why why this isn't work maybe
because you need these stats over the
entire data set then the other things
may be
working equivalently well uh but you you
can simply apply them without knowing
kind of your your principal components
okay next thing dropout dropout
has been you know one of the things
that was very important throughout the
early stages of deep learning isn't
that important anymore now dropout some
people still use it but
most people i think don't use dropout
anymore and it's very interesting to see
but
it definitely was a technique that was
used a lot
during like from alexnet to basically
like
now like the last very few years
so they say combining the predictions of
many different models is a very
successful way to reduce test errors but
it appears to be too expensive or big
neural networks
that already take several days to train
there is however a very efficient
version of
model combination that only costs about
a factor of two
during training so there's this take
this technique called
dropout then they explain it to set to
zero the output of each hidden neuron
with probability 0.5
again people didn't know about dropouts
as they do now but they introduced this
right here and they say it reduces
their not sure that they also don't say
how they
uh how much they by how much this
reduces the
training error but they say we use
dropout in the first two fully connected
layers
without dropout our network exhibits
substantial overfitting
dropout roughly doubles the number of
iterations required to converge so okay
so they did actually
make sure or they did find the actual
evidence of overfitting and saw that
dropout reduces that
and i wonder why this doesn't happen
nowadays
maybe because we have the we have less
of these fully connected layers but i
can't really imagine
um maybe because we do more augmentation
i don't i don't know or maybe
dropout is still used and i'm just i
just don't know it and don't see it
uh yeah so here they
use momentum to train this and they do
some qualitative uh analysis
um they do some qualitative analysis so
first of all they say okay they shatter
all of the previous
approaches especially also then they
build kind of ensemble methods
and they pre-train they already do
transfer learning they already pre-train
on imagenet 2011
and fine-tune then on the
imagenet 2012 right here the imagenet
and then fine-tuning on the imagenet
to reduce that error even further like
pulling
all the tricks all these things are
around still very cool
and then they look into what their
network learned so they find
that there are a number of these kind of
filters
um you see these 11 by 11 filters in the
first layer
where they show okay this really and
this was kind of already known that
these neural networks
extract filters like this like
color gradients or edge detectors in
various forms and directions
and cool to see that this one also does
so this one here
is also a very cool investigation where
they look at examples
and the red bar the red one is always
the correct label
and the bars are basically what their
model says are the top
five things and it's cool to look at
so for example here you have might as a
top one but then also
black widow cockroach tick and starfish
but
the top labels are usually also
very very good labels you can see
here grill and it assigns convertible
which you know by all means is correct
it's just not the
class that the annotators assigned to
this particular image
as well as here uh dalmatian was
uh the highest prediction of the network
where the label was actually
cherry and yeah this is this is quite
debatable right
so you can see that a lot of the
mistakes the network does
is are are you know forgivable
let's say and you can see that for
when the network doesn't do mistakes the
not only the top label
is good but a lot of the top five labels
are
also very very adequate
lastly they look at a given training set
image which these are the training set
images
right here and they look at the last
layers feature vector
and the five nearest the or the nearest
neighbors in euclidean space
of the entire training data set and
here's what you come up with so you can
see for the elephant the nearest
neighbors are all
other elephants and regard that they are
in different
poses right they don't always look the
same way
these elephants also these dogs right
here
so it's pretty cool to see that the
network actually learns
some invariances across the class and
puts images with the same label
into the same area in the embedding
space
yeah so that's their that's their paper
um they they already allude to the fact
that depth is very important it is
notable that our network's performance
degrades
if a single convolutional layer is
removed for example
removing any of the middle layers
results in a loss of about two percent
for the top one performance of the
network so the depth
really is important for achieving our
results and as you know
this spurred an area of
this burden area of
trying to build deeper and deeper
networks until resnets came along and
built ultra deep networks
they also say we did not use any
unsupervised pre-training even though
we expect that it will help especially
if we obtain enough computational power
to significantly
increase the size of the network without
obtaining a corresponding increase of
the amount of labeled data
thus far our results have improved as we
have made our network larger and trained
it longer but we still have many orders
of magnitude to go
in order to match the infra temporal
pathway of the human visual
system ultimate ultimately we would like
to use
very large and deep convolutional nets
on video sequences
where the temporal structure provides
very helpful information that is missing
of
for over far less obvious in static
images
so already the previewing of future
research here with the self-supervised
with the
many more layers and so on astounding
that this kind of foresight and of
course all of this
proved to be you know very very adequate
predictions right here and yeah so this
was the paper right here the the paper
that kicked off
deep learning um i enjoy
reading kind of these old papers
especially looking back at what
was already known what still is around
which turns out to be a lot
a lot is still around um and
the choices that people made back then
some of them
defined our modern field so
that was it for alexnet let me know what
you think in the comments
and i'll see you next time bye